we have a voice speaking of double
standards we have a voicemail number
which you can call anytime it's 2192
david p
yesterday we talked about the republican
double standard between
the trump sexual assault allegations and
the andrew cuomo sexual assault
allegations this caller
rightly points out it goes well beyond
just that as an example
hi david um you raised a good point
recently
about the double standard regarding
improper sexual allegations against uh
men in government and how you know trump
actually got off very easily but why is
cuomo being lambasted so severely and my
question is also about supreme court
justices right clarence
thomas who had very serious allegations
lodged against him by um
a subordinate employee continues to be
on the bench for many years and then
also
i'm trying to remember the name of the
one that trump appointed
brett kavanaugh i think his name is
brent i'm not i don't remember at the
moment but
that was also a very you know many very
very serious allegations of sexual
impropriety against him
but yet he continues on the supreme
court
or highest court in the nation our court
of justice
absolutely the double stan i mean listen
we can talk about the double standard
with bill clinton
we can talk about the double standard
with you know anthony weiner who is
widely denounced and abandoned by
democrats
uh you could talk about the al franken
situation certainly the clarence thomas
situation is a good one it is
endless endless endless hypocrisy and
i'm glad to have the uh
the additional examples we have a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about
milo yiannopoulos saying that he's been
converted out of homosexuality
we will talk about idaho ending
powerball because they fear foreign
participation
and we will talk about arkansas passing
a near-total abortion ban and what this
could mean for roe v wade
all of those stories and more on the
bonus show get the bonus show
every day not weekends every weekday
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com
i'll see you then